І ти чуєш, як летить снаряд з таким вжжжж звуком, і ти слухаєш - а сюди він летить, у твій будинок, чи в сусідній…
там фонтаном у неї з ноги йшла кров, штани всі мокрі були, а вона навіть цього не помітила, бо вона вела дітей до нас, і привела, врятувала їх фактично.
І найстрашніше, що він написав, що померло місто Маріуполь. Останні строки, які він написав. Тобто в очах дитини місто Маріуполь померло.
Було абсолютно нормальне життя, нормальне, комфортне, цікаве життя. У мене було дійсно цікаве життя, бо була цікава робота, працював в ІТ-сфері.
У мене були так звані хобі. Любив фотографувати, ну і люблю фотографувати.
Я знімав багато різних подій з 2014 року. Все, що відбувалося в Маріуполі, всі ці події.
Потім коли ці події військові почали вщухати трошки, я почав знімати те, що відбувається в Маріуполі цікавого - культурні події, концерти, фестивалі.
І ще для мене дуже цікава річ була - я знімав Маріуполь. Я дуже любив наше місто і… (пауза). Я робив фотопроєкт, який назвав  "Таке красиве місто"…
Мені просто подобається взяти камеру, просто пройтися цими старенькими вулицями, але якщо виділити одне, то це… Море, мабуть.
Вийти просто на море. Навіть не купатися. Я вранці любив бігати на морі, до роботи, через день-два, я намагався
бігати по вісім кілометрів - дистанція для мене була. Я бігав, отримував такий настрій гарний. Прибігаєш на море, постоїш там трохи, подивишся…
У будь-яку погоду. Робив я якісь знімки, у мене була серія знімків з пробіжок, кожного разу з пробіжки не селфі своє викладав - ось я біжу. Я не люблю селфі.
А я роблю знімок моря, а воно кожного разу різне.
24 лютого сталося те, що сталося. До останнього сподівався що цього не буде, але чекали, тому що все йшло до того.
Але до останнього я вагався, думав - ні, не піде він, бо якщо щось почнеться, то одразу за Україну вступиться Європа, Америка,
ну він же не буде воювати з усім світом!
Але, як виявилося на початку, воював він не з усім світом, а воював з Україною все ж таки, тому що світ дуже довго прокидався.
І коли полетіла на Маріуполь авіація, полетіли ракети, ніякого захисту проти всього цього у Маріуполя не було.
Якщо Київ, Харків, інші міста України великі все ж таки захищені, я не кажу, що на сто відсотків, але все ж таки є захист системами ППО,
в Маріуполі нічого цього не було. І ці російські літаки почували себе, як вдома.
Вони літають, заходять на позицію, пускають ракети на "Азовсталь", вони кидали бомби туди, куди їм хотілося.
Школа? Школа. Драматичний театр з тисячею біженців? Театр.
Третього березня був перший обстріл, тоді в нашому будинку тільки посипалося скло в деяких вікнах,
хоча десь в метрах 50 в будинки прилетіло, були прямі попадання в квартири. Ми з жінкою сидимо в коридорі, так щоб подалі від вікна…
Ми здригаємося, бо кожен постріл, кожен вибух - летять вікна, все навкруги тремтить.
І ти чуєш, як летить снаряд з таким вжжжж звуком, і ти слухаєш - а сюди він летить, у твій будинок, чи в сусідній… Це було дуже страшно.
Стук в наші двері, відкриваємо - стоїть племінниця наша, з двома своїми дітьми, усі в крові, діти в крові, вона в крові.
Каже: "Нас обстріляли, нас поранили".
Там були дійсно страшні поранення у хлопчика на спині.  На спині у нього була дуже глибока рана, повністю був здертий шкіри шматок, м’ясо…
У жінки теж на руці була глибока рвана рана, як виявилося, вона навіть не знала, як вона сюди дійшла.
Під обстрілами вона привела цих двох поранених дітей. Мати-героїня, по-іншому я не назву.
Вона навіть не знала, що в неї там і нога поранена, там фонтаном у неї з ноги йшла кров, штани всі мокрі були, а вона навіть цього не помітила,
бо вона вела дітей до нас, і привела, врятувала їх фактично.
Хлопчик постійно плакав, боляче було, він не міг поміняти положення своє, потрібно було лежати в одному положенні постійно,
він і так, і так, а воно ж тяжко дитині. Жінка теж ледь пересувалася, ми їй дві палки дали, щоб вона могла хоч якось…
Дідусь цих дітей, а цієї дівчини тато, він помер. Він теж постраждав від того обстрілу, його завалило, були переламані кістки ніг,
велика кровотеча, врятувати його вже не вдалося. У той день ми не могли вже піти поховати його, через день ми пішли поховали його просто на городі.
Єгор, хлопчик цей - ніхто про це не знав, він сам про це писав, ніхто не бачив. Він сам писав те, як він бачить.
Він там написав і про дідуся свого, який загинув, і навіть про собак своїх написав, які теж загинули, під час обстрілу одна в кімнаті була,
осколками вщент побило, другу собаку я знайшов в завалах будинку. І найстрашніше, що він написав, що померло місто Маріуполь.
Останні строки, які він написав. Тобто в очах дитини місто Маріуполь померло.
І ось ми сиділи всі в тому коридорчику і почули, що гупає дуже сильно.  Це вже були прильоти безпосередньо по нашому будинку.
У той самий час у будинок вривається група чеченців, усіх виганяють на вулицю. Вони не давали часу навіть на те, щоб зібратися.
У нас щось там було вже зібрано, і от тільки те, що було, ми встигли схопити і взяли ще пару термосів з гарячою водою.
Це все, що ми встигли забрати з собою. І оця поранена жінка, яка кульгала з двома палками,
її діти і ми, ми вимушені були піти з дому і пішли до сусіднього дому, сховалися там у підвалі.
Ми зайшли у той підвал, години не пройшло, ми чуємо страшні жіночі крики: "Навіщо вони вийшли, навіщо вони вийшли?".
Вона все повторювала одну й ту саму фразу. А сталося те, що у цей дім теж попав снаряд і на якомусь поверсі пожежа почалася.
І молодий хлопець, знаю навіть його ім’я - Денис Мєдведєв - він вискочив подивитися, який поверх горить, щоб спробувати гасити.
Але тільки він вибіг на вулицю, його вбиває снайпер. До нього біжить його батько з під’їзду, кидається. Тут же вбивають його батька.
Той же снайпер. Вони лежали поруч один з одним навпроти виходу з під’їзду. Мабуть, більше тижня вони там лежали.
На наступний день я вийшов вранці подивитися на наш будинок.
Стояв чорний будинок, жодного вікна, голі тільки дірки від вікон.
Я пішов у нашу квартиру подивитися, у мене навіть ключі були з собою.
Голі стіни абсолютно і купа попелу, я не знаю, 200 чи скільки міліметрів товщиною.
Чеченців і зовнішньо було видно. 35.07 Вони були дуже гарно екіпіровані, всі такі кремезні,
Вони були дуже такі жорстокі, навіть коли розмовляли з ними просто.
Були там і російські солдати, вони теж відрізнялися. І були "ДНР". Ну "ДНР" взагалі були, знаєте, на серйозних воїнів ніяк не схожі.
Вони були одягнені в таке простеньке, екіпіровка була схожа на спецовку камуфляжну.
Якщо починали з ними спілкуватися, хтось питав: ну-от, навіщо ви нам побили все?
Вони казали, дуже багато разів від них чув: "Ми вісім років страждали, тепер постраждайте і ви".
У якийсь день ми вже почали ловити українське радіо на середніх хвилях на старенькому приймачі, там дивом спіймали і почули, що
о другій дня буде їхати колона від "Порт Сіті", є в нас такий торговий центр, буде колона на Запоріжжя.
У нас всі речі були зібрані, бабусю на коляску, домовилися з сусідами, відвезли туди всі речі.
Там дійсно були люди на евакуацію, зайняли чергу, але в той день ми простояли десь до півсьомої вечора, був вітер, було дуже холодно, бабуся наша замерзла,
ми її чим могли утепляли, всі теплі речі з валізи дістали, але вона все одно мерзла, все рівно ніхто не приїхав.
Тричі ми намагалися виїхати ось цими евакуаційними автобусами. Потім ми вже домовилися з хлопцем, який зголосився нас везти туди.
Із Маріуполя ми виїхали у суботу 30 квітня і ось вчора шостого вранці ми приїхали до Києва.
У тому будинку, де ми знаходилися в підвалі, у сусідньому під'їзді був там такий Євген, його як і мене звали.
Він бачив, що я ще на початку березня ходив, знімав, як після обстрілів було, він це запам'ятав, і він, коли прийшло "МГБ" і розпитувало, що там СБУ,
чи жив у вас хтось з СБУ, він, не довго думаючи, здав мене: "У підвалі тут у нас живе "кореспондент", як він сказав.
І, звісно, вони мене підізвали, взяли в оборот, почали допитувати, що ти тут знімав, розповідай.
Кажу, ну вибачте, знімав дітей, людей, як вони тут багаття палять, тобто нічого такого я не знімав.
Але нічого, що я знімав, у мене не залишилося, тому що квартира згоріла, можу показати. У підвалі два фотоапарати згоріли,
а вони там дійсно згоріли, якщо хочете, можу повести, показати. Усі свої акторські здібності застосував, бо я ще маю хобі - граю в театрі.
То, мабуть, гарно зіграв цю роль.
-=-=-=-==
Ми коли стояли на евакуацію,  проходила колона в сторону Запоріжжя - дуже багато техніки, танки, БТР-и з буквою V англійською.
І були такі дідусі, йшли там саме з риночку, який відкрили недалеко на в'їзді в Маріуполь, і махають так привітливо цим воякам. Були такі.
Розбитий будинок, напіврозбитий, а люди з вікна висовуються - іде взвод цих рашистів, а вони їм: "Слава росії!".
Тобто були й такі. Люди навіть у цих обставинах нічого не зрозуміли.
Будинок бабусі і навіть наш багатоквартирний будинок були теж неподалік від "Азовсталі", вони виявилися в епіцентрі цих всіх бойових дій.
Там є такі ділянки, як-то кажуть - Хатинь. Від будинків нічого не залишилося зовсім.
А є там ділянки, які були повністю зруйновані, ще й спалені, а в деяких досі ще лежать їх господарі, трупи людей,
навіть можна побачити, якщо підходиш до будинку.
Хлопець один пішов працювати, щоб дітей прогодувати, їх найняли на розбір завалів. І він пішов працювати, але не зміг там довго працювати,
бо з кожного будинку, який вони розгрібають, 80-100 трупів. 80-100 трупів.
Біля нас, біля мого дому недалеко, були офіси і в них були великі підвали. Там ховалися люди.
У цей підвал влітає авіабомба, їх закидає плитами. Це була ще навіть Україна в нас.
Приїжджають ДСНС-ники, намагаються ці плити підняти якось, вони не змогли це зробити. Там залишилися люди, вони досі там. Скільки їх там, ніхто не знає.
У тому стані, як зараз, для мене Маріуполя більше немає. У цьому місті жити зараз неможливо.